panel here
um and we've just moved everything up
ten minutes but we'll have two speakers
and then q a and then lunch so
um oh i should introduce myself i'm
salome fully
um i was a dli postdoctoral fellow with
helen and lee who's going to be speaking
here shortly and
my affiliation i'm an incoming associate
professor of law at university of
michigan i'm going to turn it over to
lee mcguigan now who's at
unc chapel hill thanks
yeah i've got uh yeah
everyone
thanks so much for the opportunity to
speak with you today in the invitation
um i'm gonna talk about some uh
collaboration between myself and jake
golden fine whom i will summon to the
front to answer all your difficult
questions later on so um
so
a paper is called laws consumers and
platform users this is very much a work
in progress so i certainly welcome any
critical constructive feedback about it
um we're gonna be talking i'm gonna be
talking about online behavioral
advertising which probably many of you
know what i mean when i say that but
just briefly we're talking about a
variety of socio-technical systems some
involving artificial intelligence but
not exclusively about artificial
intelligence that are involved in doing
things like classification scoring
probabilistic predictions that
ultimately determine the distribution
and pricing of advertisements so these
are systems that
basically determine what ads are going
to be placed where to whom at what cost
and or what conditions and so on
um
and so
uh
where this paper started was i came to
jake noticing this apparent
inconsistency in the governance of
online behavioral advertising which is
that when you enter into a privacy
policy or a set of terms of service
going into a platform like facebook for
example and i'm going to use platform
sort of as a shorthand but um where
facebook or instagram would be
paradigmatic of like a self-contained
so-called wall garden of ad tech that
has these integrated systems but you can
also think about it in terms of the more
decentralized but still interconnecting
systems that serve advertisements on
websites and mobile apps and all the
rest of it so when i say platform i'm
speaking generally about those sorts of
things and i think what we're going to
say kind of holds across them although
there's particularities among each of
them um so when you enter into the into
the privacy policies the presumption is
that you are a rational actor you're
doing what's what's something called
privacy self-management
which is to say that
you have a relatively stable endowment
of preferences and capacities and by
being informed about the terms of
service you are able to make reasoned
utility maximizing judgments to give up
your personal information in exchange
for the benefits of personalization
you'll see advertisements that are
relevant to you you'll see pricing
that's personalized and all the rest of
it um
yet the contradiction for me was that on
the other side of the that contract when
you enter into the platform environment
the presumption motivating all of that
collection of information and the
profiling that determines the
distribution of advertisements presumes
that people are not rational but in fact
predictably irrational and over the last
10 years or so the advertising industry
has really absorbed a lot of insights
from behavioral economics which tries to
identify these cognitive and heuristic
biases that people use in their
judgments
and integrate those into basically
making better bets about what ads are
going to pay off what's going to
generate clicks and all the rest of it
um so i came to jake with this you know
somewhat naive recognition of this
inconsistency and it aligned very well
with some work he was doing about a
similar sort of contradiction or tension
between the liberal subject constructed
in the law
and the sort of correlational pattern
subject that's presumed and
operationalized within
uh cybernetic systems or platform
environments what jake was calling
control environments
um
and so the turn into this question of
who is the actor that's presumed and
codified in the governance of online
platforms
right
the presumption being that that the
rational capacities that are assigned to
the individuals who enter into these
contracts or and then into these
platforms matter for the governance of
the systems that the protections or
exposure that these people are subject
to depend on these presumptions and how
they're codified in the law and then
within the socio-technical environment
of the platform
um
and so basically what we're tracking
um
[Music]
sorry i'm maybe messed up my slides a
little bit
there we go um is the passage
from the consumer to the platform user
and
this passage is governed by a number of
legal regimes which jake can probably
describe to you better than i can but
i'll go through them briefly so first is
notice and choice this is the basic
paradigm for privacy self-management
where you're notified of the terms of
conditions and you consent to them
[Music]
it's based in things like rational
choice theory um which the next speaker
is probably the most expert person in
the world on that so i'm not going to
say too much about it but basically it
presumes this
typical liberal subject of law and
economics
and thus makes their choices to consent
to the terms of service legitimate
within the law
um but then there's so
what jake did was complicate this
dichotomy i'd set up and find that
there's actually some really interesting
wrinkles so then
another sphere of legal influence over
the set of relationships is consumer
protection law
and um without going too far into it
this is an area of the law to also in
some ways absorb behavioral economics
and basically come to understand that
the marketplace actor is not this you
know rational utility maximizing actor
although they may seek to maximize their
utility they operate under these
constraints particularly the cognitive
biases and so on that i mentioned and so
in a sense the project of consumer
protection is to reduce the exposure of
individuals to the sorts of
vulnerabilities and exploitations that
would be expected of taking advantage of
these cognitive biases as i'll describe
in a little bit it's basically
recuperating the rational subject so
that he or she can stand on their own
legs
when we're now assuming that they don't
actually
act rationally
as the notice and choice
regime would presume
and then there's a data privacy which
can be represented by things like the
gdpr and other data protection laws that
are coming in to effect
it basically combine combines notice and
choice with among other things some
rights that allow
individuals to access the information
that's collected and used about them in
these platform environments and to in
some sense have what's called
informational self-determination to
narrate themselves who their data
persona is going to be basically
um and so these are these are three
things
that um i'll kind of get to the punch
line in a minute about what they mean in
terms of the work that they're doing
within the governance of online behavior
advertising and informational capitalism
more generally
um
so this is basically all jake um where i
come in is that i um
i studied the history of advertising and
technology so what we were interested in
was the ways that these match up in
interesting ways with the how the
advertising business has constructed
consumers in variable and somewhat
duplicitous ways to basically straddle
the the some of these um elements of
consumers and usual end users
uh without going too far into it the
advertising industry has always
maintained this sort of um variable
understanding of of how individuals make
choices in marketplace settings because
it's been really beneficial for them in
a number of ways so
in some circumstances there's the
presumption that people act rationally
and that advertising provides
individuals with the information they
need to execute their rational
capacities within a marketplace setting
right
um
on the other hand when advertising
professionals are speaking amongst
themselves to clients and customers
the individual is presented um as being
suggestible is the term that they used
to use drawing on psychology at the turn
of the 20th century to create this idea
of um of a consumer who can be moved by
professional influence and this in many
ways elevates the status of advertising
professionals right if you presume that
people can their behavior can be
predicted and influenced by your
specialist activities and that in fact
you can't count on them to act
rationally that we need to exercise some
sort of a paternalistic form of
management over them advertising
professionals become really important to
the functioning of markets
um
and so
these sort of dynamics are played out in
lots of different ways the advertising
industry is generally extremely
opportunistic in the way that it
exploits science and technology so it
will take whatever theories and findings
are useful to satisfying clients and
disarming superiors and so on
but basically where the industry has
landed more recently is
toward thinking about individuals
particularly this is in the online
behavioral advertising context
not so much through this concept of like
coherent
personal autonomous individuals but more
as like sets of patterns and
probabilistic
correlations that can be mapped and and
dissembled reassembled
in lots of different ways
in ways that complicate some of these
forms of legal governance
particularly if you think about
something like data privacy
we have this idea of informational
self-determination
um that's really complicated by a
platform environment where human
scrutability is not important to the
conception of the individual who's
actualized in that platform environment
we don't need to be able to narrate
their identity they don't need to be
their gender doesn't need to be assigned
in a way that would align with their own
sense of self right it's a probabilistic
guess often that changes in different
contexts and
really depends more on the environment
so um
we call this the two-faced consumer of
advertising
uh i don't i didn't mean to do all these
weird uh things so now this is here's
the point i want to get to and i'm going
to read a little bit from our paper just
to try and do justice to it so um
the point we're trying to make is that
the contradictions between the legal
subjects of privacy self-management
consumer protection and data protection
on the one hand and the two-phase
subject of platform-mediated advertising
on the other is that they work to
stabilize a set of social relations uh
supporting and scaffolding consumer
rationality not only protects against
the exploitation of consumer
vulnerabilities but is essential to the
political concept of consumer
sovereignty that puts markets in charge
of economic production and consumer
consumers in charge of markets so that
is to say that consumer protection law
doesn't just protect people and markets
but it protects the sovereign consumer
as a salient legal and political
identity that is necessary for
legitimizing and authorizing market
capitalism as a form of socialization a
social organization
so
you know traditional uh critiques of
capitalist political economy identify
how workers autonomously selling their
labor through employment contracts
participate in building a set of social
relations that results in worker
subordination and we argue that the
two-phase consumer sort of articulates
that dynamic in informational capitalism
that the adoption of behavioral
economics and consumer protection
and the proliferation of data protection
laws work to stabilize the social
relations of the platform by holding up
the human as a rational consumer while
at the same time exploiting their data
and protection as a predictably
irrational consumer
so the transition of the consumer into
the user speaks to the transition of a
human subject through different
iterations of capitalist legal and
social relations
so
in other words what we're saying is that
rationality is not so much like a
cognitive endowment but rather a
variable an environment environmentally
and institutionally determined construct
its evidence deficiencies in the raw
freedom of a liberal chooser beset by
systemic biases and vulnerabilities call
into action the devices of alternatively
data protection to enable narrative
authorship over one's identity or
consumer protection to scaffold
rationalities such that the autonomous
and utility maximizing subject can stand
on its own a monument to the validity of
market mechanisms
so this rational and calculating
consumer is thus free to enter into the
terms of platform service but inside the
platform a peculiar set of devices
scaffolds a radically different subject
the platform user not autonomous and
self-determined but fragmentary
correlational probabilistic
environmentally contingent
so privacy regulators have continued to
advance notice and choice privacy
regimes framing digital privacy as a
solution to market failure subordinating
privacy's norman normative content to
ideals of market efficiency
so then what is really achieved through
this persistent contradiction and its
operationalization within the governance
of uh platform capitalism or
informational capitalism
what we're suggesting is that the
contradiction is central to the ways
that platform capitalism relates itself
to individuals and embeds itself into
the communicative dimensions of everyday
life to that end we argued that even if
supplemented with whatever expressions
of behavioral economics consumer
protection might construe
notice and choice not only fails to
deliver meaningful privacy but its real
productive function is to harbor a set
of relations that legitimize the
strategic overlapping of market
mechanisms and data intensive
algorithmic management infrastructures
so that's the work of the two-faced
advertiser the two-faced consumer in the
advertising platform environment
yeah that was amazing and like right on
time so
um thank you so much felipe um
oh yeah great
as mike as leah's d miking
um i will in the meantime uh introduce
sonia amade um from the university of
helsinki it's our second speaker
thank you i was so
engrossed in that it's the incoming oh
my goodness
i would just starting
you